[Music]
i'm rhett and i'm link
and this is our episode of spectrum
[Music]
we're rhett and link from good mythical
morning good mythical morning this is
where we make our show right here at
this desk i wasn't repeating the name of
the show i was actually
greeting you rhett and link good
mythical morning red lincoln mythical
morning
here is the first prompt our wives
get jealous of our friendship three
two one go let's see so agree is over
here
well i'm just on agree i mean we've
known each other since
first grade uh i met my wife my
sophomore year in college i think she
gets a little fed up with
all of the inside jokes all the
experiences that we have
from childhood that you know she's just
kind of left out well
my wife has specifically confirmed this
several times
because sometimes i'll get home she'll
ask me about something i'll be like i
don't really want to talk about this
because i like already talked about it
on ear biscuits
or like or i already talked about it
okay
and she's like oh you've already spent
all day with your best friend talking
about what you wanted to talk about
and now you're not willing to just
listen to my podcast crack the door open
on conversation with me
yeah it's kind of that's how it is yeah
when we go to
parties or like public get-togethers
people tend to associate
the two of us with each other even if
we're there with our wives
you know if i were christy i would feel
this way too i understand why that's
frustrating
christy and i will be married uh 22
years
in may no is it 21 years
we got married in the year 2000 so it
should be easy what year
is it 2022. yeah see
21 years our marriage is old enough to
drink boy do we get sloshed
our show is getting repetitive
three two one
go
huh you think we're somewhat repetitive
okay this is why i said somewhat agree
because i don't think
that being somewhat repetitive isn't
necessarily a bad thing
the repetitive nature of what we do is
actually one of the things
that makes people want to watch it they
know it's going to be two guys sitting
at a desk
we're in our 10th year doing this show
there is a familiarity with that that
gives people
comfort it's dependable yeah i somewhat
disagree with the answer
because people joke in the comments so
you guys are running out of ideas if it
were just up to the two of us
yeah we probably would have ran out of
idea years ago
but we got a great team that helps
develop the concepts and keep things
fresh
and hey we're up for almost anything
[Laughter]
listen there is no bottom to the well of
ideas it's
not going to run dry right like fossil
fuels
i have thought about quitting
three two one
go
okay all right
i mean first of all i'm living the dream
i hang out with my best friend since
first grade and
people just put stuff in front of me to
eat
and discuss and experience we're very
fortunate to have
a lot of artistic and business
independence you know
mythical is ours yes we're living the
dream
is it very difficult and taxing
yes 100 it requires putting yourself out
there
trying a bunch of other things that
people never see trying to manage
a growing company i mean the reason i
started going to therapy
was it was when we were doing the
what we call gmm 22 it was four or five
videos every single day
i just remember all of a sudden i
couldn't see out of one eye i went to
the doctor it's basically when your
retina has
fluid behind it and it is
thought to be a stress induced condition
in fact
i would tell my wife i'm like i'm not
stressed out it's like i i can handle
anything
and she was like yeah but your back is
messed up you've got like
skin issues i can tell that there's
something on your mind when you're at
home and now you've got this thing where
you can't see out of one eye
you know there's something called a
physical manifestation of stress for
people who are not good
processing their emotions and feelings
that they're having
you should go see a therapist and so
that was the beginning of me
understanding that like
oh yeah i haven't been actually dealing
with
how much we commit to and how
constantly we are being we are engaging
with things
it was just too much to manage uh well
um i've got hemorrhoids
yeah yeah where's that
la has changed us three
two one go
anything goes here man
i mean you don't bat an eye on anything
back home lots of
eyes were batted at lots of things in
rural north carolina you're not exposed
to as many perspectives once we moved
out here
you meet people that are that are
different and that have different
experiences
and they become your friends you know
anything that you can keep at arm's
length is not going to impact
you in the same way that if it's a
trusted friend somebody that you love
we just celebrated our 10th year in los
angeles
the only reason i didn't put strongly
agree is there's certain things about
who i am that are never going to change
just based on
where i come from you know we even said
that in the video that we made when we
were coming across the country
that was like we're not going to let la
change us one of the things that people
around north carolina have seem to
express a little concern about is like
we tell them what we're doing and
they're like
don't you boys go hollywood on us now
don't forget where you're from
i've kind of come to the conclusion that
like no stagnation
staying the same is bad don't you want
to constantly be evolving don't you want
to constantly be becoming
the next and better version of yourself
and it can happen anywhere
but it's happened in a slightly
different way in los angeles
and i'm happy with it is there anything
that you guys miss about home
um i guess not no
no i mean i mean there's plenty of stuff
that i miss my family and
bojangles i gotta add to that list as
well
you know getting some of that fried
chicken and dirty rice
oh gosh give me back there baby oh i
miss home so much i got some dirty rides
i don't know why all of a sudden i took
on this character
i am glad we opened up about leaving
christianity
three two one
go
for sure the decision to open up about
leaving christianity was one that was
it wasn't an easy decision and we did
experience backlash we did experience
people saying
never watching another one of your
videos i'm no longer a fan
we had some new people come in and say
hey i didn't know you guys
had this side to you i didn't and so i'm
kind of interested in what you might
have to say
yeah i can safely say that i don't have
any regrets in deciding to share my
spiritual deconstruction story and the
journey that
i'm still on and kind of filling the
gaps
for the mythical beast who didn't
understand
a big chunk of what made us who we
each are as individuals now it started
to feel kind of like a secret
now on the other side of that i
experienced a freedom that i didn't have
to be more of myself
you know when you find yourself talking
about things and just
crying you're like oh this is this is a
new place we haven't been
before it was almost like pulling a cork
out
or releasing a valve let's just lean
into this vulnerability
and invite people into the process and
see what happens
and there's just been a freedom and sort
of this feeling that like a burden has
been lifted
but when it comes to these spiritual
things it's like i don't
have it figured out every day that
passes
i'm more and more overwhelmed with the
what i don't know what i don't know
about the nature of the world what i
don't know about
anything and so it's kind of cool
to be like hey let's just make a
connection and that's that can be a
beautiful thing
as we're experiencing but it's not a
decisive thing and it's
certainly not a divisive thing
there have been challenges that almost
ended our friendship
three two one
go
i didn't want to give the impression
that we don't have heavy conversations
and that we don't
get into things like oh you hurt my
feelings when you did this
or professionally i'm seeing our
business trajectory in this way but it's
nothing that
has ever threatened the foundation of
our friendship or
our working relationship the
relationship is only trumped by our
relationships with our wives
we talk about our relationship being a
lot like a marriage
where there's sort of a commitment that
underlies and precedes
the relationship i did not go all the
way to strongly disagree because i
reserved the right for us
to break out you know i'm not going to
say it's impossible
there's a healthy assessment of reality
associated with us saying you know what
it could happen
we're not going to ignore that it could
happen we're going to make sure it
doesn't happen
right i see myself making videos
in ten years three
two one go
making videos is a very broad thing to
me
that just means making something
that the final form is visual
entertainment i don't know if it's going
to be
good mythical morning and ear biscuits
i don't know if you two will be around
sometimes i just think i could just like
buy a van and just
live in it and you don't think you'd
make videos in that van
and not even make videos in it i mean 10
years is a long time i'll be
53 years old i mean first of all who who
really wants to see
a 53 year old i feel like i'm going to
be making videos for myself
by that point regardless of what happens
i don't have any plans of being like you
know what i think i'm just done creating
because creating is going to be my hobby
until i can no longer
move i strongly agree
that this was a rewarding experience
and i strongly disagree that i don't
agree with you
i feel like i should incorporate this
system into every conversation with my
wife and children
yeah instead of sitting down at the
table and saying
how was your day and what'd you do at
school today and getting nothing
i want this to be my kitchen table
thanks for searching our souls
i hope we didn't say anything we're
gonna have to retract later
you don't get like no one has ever slid
into my dm to be like
hey i want to tower over you
[Music]
i've sent or received nudes
wait how do you not like send or receive
news like wait wait
are we saying nudes yes oh my god i
thought we were saying
news n-e-w-s
[Music]
you